Hello. I'm the nostalgia critic guy remember it so you don't have to well the big summer blockbusters are coming up and guess which ones
have the most hype
aside from that
that's like from that one [to]
For the sake of this joke. I'm gonna say the [avengers] and prometheus
yes, people are excited to see these two big films premiere and why shouldn't they be it got one film directed by Joss Whedon and
another film about the Alien franchise
Quit so much build-up between these two movies you gotta wonder why nobody thought to put Joss Whedon and the alien franchise
together at some point oh my God Alien resurrection my
God
Yeah, how many of you knew [that] the geek got a Sci-Fi actually started off writing one of the dumbest Sci-Fi flicks ever to hit?
The screen the sequel was made in Fam response to the fact that nobody was satisfied with the last and supposed final alien
So they made this flake to try and end it on a stronger when really it was Hollywood's way of saying hey
You think that's a bad way than to franchise
Take a look at how else we can fuck up this turkey throw in the very natural
Selection of the director from Amelie and you get a film that surprisingly sluts out the dignity of alien creatures
Who are more Phallic shape than out? So let's see why in space nobody can hear you sock this is Alien resurrection
So they waste no time on the resurrection part
We see ripley played again by sigourney weaver brought back to life through cloning 200 years later after her death
Jesus bringing people back from 200 years ago there are so many rap battles that can evolve from this
she's brought back so that scientists can reproduce the alien creature that was implanted inside of her and
Seeing how this is a Joss whedon script I expect at least one of those mad scientist's [dancing] along
I'm looking at you warm tongue blood and guts
Slimy -
Shoulda Stopped at Movie -
Ripley is kept alive and flown in a [cell] until she regains consciousness
Now from a symbolic standpoint the bank represents rebirth and entering a new world of life
But from a reality standpoint. They're just dicks [fuckin] around with her
Hey, harry, you got the giant novelty condom from Spencer's yeah
Why don't we go ahead and put her inside it you've been dreaming about this [for] a while haven't so what if I have?
But we quickly see that this ripley is different from the one before
As some of her dna has mixed in with the alien and made her a different kind of creature for example
She thinks the word fork his fuck
fork
Fuck she said fuck. It's funny. It's a queen. How did you know that? She'll breed?
You'll die. I think you will find that
Things have changed a great deal since your time yes, like they have answered proof cells to keep the aliens in a way
They don't well at least they have a general who understands the scientific risks at stake. [oh] [wait]
They don't well at least they're not just relying on a bunch of space
Pirates to bring up their incredibly important card - oh for God's sakes this operations as airtight as a [strain] [door]
Yeah, things have come a long way since before but dumb is still dumb
Don't cut the [russel] about [600] meters and give a little scare so like I said before a bunch of renegade
Space Pirates bring prisoners for the scientists to use as breeding grounds for the aliens could you have a please sir?
What could you [answer] please by the way that's ron [perlman] that's one of the pilots there. No weapons allowed on board sir
my own recipe
Way [more] dangerous could I say my line any closer to the camera? [oh]?
When I [kick] the chair why yes that would make a lot of sense?
When own a writer playing the part of coal and truth be told I'm sorry
I'm just not that big a fan of her acting why because every scene
She's in looks like a five-year-old about to throw a temper tantrum
He's conducting illegal experiments, and you were planning on letting us this we can't trust her [I]
wanted ice cream
It doesn't take long for them to come across Ripley was just as eager to chew the scenery as the aliens are
Know if you don't want to play basketball. I know some other indoor sports come on now. Give me the ball
I
Guess she's wearing her [ear]. Fuck [hughes] today
Yeah, I bet you didn't know that her alien Dna gave her super Spider-Man powers, [too]
The hell are you [ah]?
Yes, and the ability to shoot a basket without even looking no doubt another chilling [side-effect] of the alien Dna these things must have taken
her sports very seriously ah
[so] for a while, we see people on the ship Mosey around being boring
[I] think [this] is supposed to establish character development, but let's face it
We're just getting an early peek at the buff [any] we know these guys are Alien chow
We're just looking at the clock until they get munched on
Then there's bizarre shit like this you
[know] it's at moments like this where I realized the only reason we let brad dourif Act is because we're afraid of what he'll do
if he doesn't
I
Have a date with six-Year-old boy
Come on. You were putting the moves on him
Meanwhile cole tries to break into the security system. That is so high-tech and so
airtight that she has a key chain of choices [to] foil it with
Thank God. They didn't stage in one of the bajillion guards they have [onboard] this flying crock-pot
well
You're Gonna kill me or what?
There's no point is there?
It's true. They'll keep making sequels without her you [got] to help me stop this thing before it gets loose
It's too late
You can't stop it. There's lesbian [t's] for the trailer better down it to rub my tea party. [I] don't care [I]
Can make it stop did I mention this director was french very very french?
go on
Get out of here
They're looking for you
And the ability to psychically tell when people are looking for other people yet another chilling if not confusing
side-effect of the Alien DnA
right next to re-enacting scenes from wild things
I
Think you're Gonna fight that this was very ill-advised, but [cole] gets clawed
And they suspect she's some sort of terrorist trying to stop their plans
So they capture the rest of the [pirates] to question them look I don't care whether you [knew] or not
You brought a terrorist on board a military vessel and as far as I am concerned
You will die with her and I get to say my lives more flamboyant
Where's the other one with the chair?
Don't ever touch me
Ever uh wouldn't it make more sense if he just kept the gun no well, maybe they're trying to find the peaceful route christy
Okay, Nellie was pointless for him not to have kept the gun stop your weapons
You drop that biggest shit release Dr.. [mann] push on you. Oh
Jesus why stop there there's so many other obvious objects, you could have bounced it off [of]
Well that's going on the aliens in this cell trying to figure out [a] clever way out
Buddy, there's two kinds of aliens on this ship those who like the Nostalgia critics transformer cartoon review and those?
Who don't like the Nostalgia critics transformer cartoon review which are you? I just would have liked to have seen a more in character
[where] John's Cameo was pointless?
Mathema Scriber got old
It just wasn't from do you
So the acid blood from the body breaks through the walls and allows the aliens to escape again
No, guards around to protect the most dangerous fucking thing in the Galaxy at the moment
[he'll] they [don't] even call security after this happens. They just look over the mez making way for this obvious kill
Hey
Oh poor
This leads to the general and his army [of] shoulder hair to do the most badass thing this division can think oh
Run the fuck away
Rhomboid pussies from the thing we were supposed to be guarding this whole time the aliens try to break in the ripley cell
But she has a plan to break open the metal wall with her bare hands cut her skin use her acid blood to short out
The wires thus opening the door oh
Her she could have just used the exact same strength to open the door get that acid blood doesn't flow much to the brain oh
Boy, it's like cup of noodles this looks like a job [for] a pointless CG shot
In honor of those who proudly run away like little girls
proof that [Dan] [Hadiya] can act with just a small portion of his brain
so of course after the fucking army runs away from these things our space pirates try to hightail it as well [or]
[they] stop and walk slowly in the other direction rather than make it to their only escape route
[level] [5] sweet delicious idiots on Level 5
So this guy whose name you came from member gets axed off and they come across suspect number one
It's okay. I'll give you guys a few minutes to run come on man. Type ago time to go [dick] [rat] alarm in it
Yeah, I should probably chase after them
I'm so distracted. I just can't focus you know
I think my mind was [just] distracted by that ad I saw earlier today, how'd it go again?
Yeah, that was it okay
I think they've had time to simmer in their own sweat let me just use these pSychic alien powers
I just figured out we had to not figure out that one of my own kind is about to shoot
Fuck, [I] better still get a snow cone
was it everything you hoped for what is your obsession with turning this into a lesbo quick, so
Who do I have to fuck to get off this boat?
We all know who you like a fuck [seriously] where did this come from [let's] get out of here. No wait a second here
She was the host for these monsters. She's not human
[why] wanted a horse not a pony she comes so they come across the wheelchair guy?
Yeah, I know he has a name, but let's face it
You're just gonna [hold] the wheelchair guy and they also stumble across the other cloning experiments before Ripley was made
Now this scene is creative and allows for some cool visuals, but when you really get down to it
It's totally pointless would you really miss anything if this part of the story was cut out?
aside from Deform Ripley boobie
A painless poison will do
And I'm sure this will in no way attract other aliens aboard the ship at all
Whatever you do
Don't draw the aliens attention except for very loudly
Destroying as much equipment as possible very still first up must be a chick thing
They come across one [of] the prisoners who has an alien inside of him and like morons they decide to bring him along
I'm so looking forward to not getting attached to this character because
[obviously] he's going to die yet the same chances as a lawyer in a theme park filled with
Dinosaurs [odds] aren't in your favor guy. I'm okay
I'm okay
They come across a flooded area where they discovered the aliens have set a trap [for] them to birth more babies. Oh
Shit, that's bad as you remember in the first film once those things get on they never come off the more and more you pull
The tighter and tighter it get or she just rips it off like waxing a mustache
We can see the other alien movies [where] these things really like just wanting a housefly off of you the whole time
[Annoy]
Look like the black guy from earlier still has calculated aiming that would make basil of Baker Street blush
Occupied by the square look at my sauce [nice] triangle dividing [Gautam] expensable of opposing forces motion and adjusting for the difference in equilibrium
This allows them to start climbing up just as one [of] the doctors from before turns against them way too trusting
Allow me to put this in [my] bitch later folder trust me. I'll put it to good use [so]
[the] Alien jumps out of the water and tries to follow our heroes
Wait a minute. You're telling me that this guy can hit with impeccable
accuracy any angle any position knocking off of every solid object he can find but a
7-foot Alien standing right the fuck in front of him is constantly throwing off his Aim
[do] you need to wear a giant bullseye on his head [boom] God this is embarrassing?
He does finally managed [to] shoot the damn thing, but it hangs on to [his] foot
Which he could easily kick off, but for some reason he decides to separate himself to save the rest of the crew
now
Let us have a moment of silence for that black guy you
[know] I don't think that fall would have killed [aah] he's dead. There's no other aliens down there together not now. He's dead
He could easily just swim out of there any chance you. Why can't you just accept the
Incredibly rare fact that a black guy has died in a horror film
Even though the fates hunkers were destroyed how does that even sure?
But it turns out cole made it out. Okay despite the fact that she was shot
Why because she's a robot of course you're an odd Todd
Robots designed by Robust, right
And all right this leads me to my bitch later folder first off if she's a robot
Why did a bullet hurt her the robots in the past never took so long to recover from anything like that?
Second since she fell in the water why didn't the alien attack her when it had the chance?
They're smart they know she's a threat and third if she could swim out of the water, okay?
Why a [fuc] card and the black guy you racist. [I] don't think you know what that word means
So after figuring that out lately gets caught by the aliens, but is surprisingly not hard
Hey
things get even worse when the doctor catches up with the crew and holds cole hostage
We move [alright] put a cap right with his little white brain
Go ahead. She's a fucking robot drop a weapon
Yeah, sure drop the weapons
It's not like robots can survive anything extreme except being shot in the chest being torn in half and getting your head fucking decapitated
But aside from that robots are very sensitive be careful
Here's another goofy scene the prisoner from earlier feels the aliens starting to come out
So what does he do what anyone would do if they felt something starting to pop out of their stomach?
Gets up goes for a walk beats the living shit out of a guy and then has the alien birth through his head
Keeping the need for creativity, but [that] makes no sense
I don't remember john hurt going through anything like this in the first alien movie [oh] my God
I feel something about [to] breast out of my chest. [oh], that's strange. I have a sudden burst of energy, okay?
I want [to] [Jessa] sighs oh, yes, do a little typo. Oh it's kicking
And just when you thought things couldn't get any sillier in this movie
We find out that brad dourif is still alive
Throwing a really fucking last-minute plot exposition that Ripley's dna mixed with the queen's Dna now allows her to give birth
To a new [life-form]. [oh], and you thought his acting as chucky was subtle. Take a look at this little piece of shakespearean gold
I have no idea why I'm cheerfully invested, but the new baby doesn't take to our mother kindly
A
beautiful beautiful
little baby
You know this performance is like a human representation of alien porn
Fanfiction, [I] really have no [idea] what's going on through his mind, and I think for the sake of all humanity
It should remain that way. He should just come with a sign saying brad door no questions [dammit] no questions
So ripley gets away. It jumps onto the ship leaving for Earth, but of course that's not bubble sneaks aboard to
Put it down
[I]
Really love how they try to make you feel for this thing you were introduced to in the last 10 minutes of the movie
Especially [when] they're given these big puppy-dog eyes. [I] just [want] to eat the manatee and develop wings
He's dead a [climb]
Even it is most psychotic. They still try to throw that shit in it's pretty emotionally clustered
I just wanna play with the puppies cocksucking motherfucker
Mommy why would you do this to me [Shelby] trash and hell?
But they shoot a hole in the window which forces him [to] literally get sucked out
I
Want a princess Gesell?
best death ever weapon
So I'm sure a hole in the window of a ship re-entering Earth's
Atmosphere wouldn't cause any complications at all so they reenter fine and look over the new [world] they have to explore
And after all [that] lesbian build-up. We finally get our gay kiss for the movie
Fuck you
So that was alien resurrection
What the hell happened?
It's so weird watching a movie franchise like this
Go, so bizarrely bad, especially with to be fair a lot of good people working on it
The story has a million [whole] the characters are [just] there [to] die the idea of mixing Ripley's Dna with the Alien is
Interesting but doesn't add too much if anything at all some of the gross-out deaths are creatively over-the-top
But for the most part, it's just a lame lame flick and a really disappointing way to end
What is now the poorly named [Alien] Trilogy?
Personally, I'll take my chances with prometheus after all when is Ridley Scott ever directed a bad movie let me dream
I'm the Nostalgia Critic. I remember it so you don't
[maybe] my [heart's] on fire
If you refuse me, how do you lose me then you'll be left alone? [oh], baby turbo and tell me I'm your
Check please must be a chick thing